le physique c'est le réseau le réseau
d'aujourd'hui il n'est pas capable de
faire x 2 mais non pas du tout et
d'ailleurs même même si a pas de
développement si on s'en occupe pas il
va se paupériser ce réseau c'est la
faute à fait c'est pas la faute à vous
c'est pas la faute au gouvernement
actuel c'est un héritage du passé ont
codé l'histoire si je la résume le tgv a
absorbé toute l' angola grande partie de
la deûle de la substance économique de
la sncf qui pendant des décennies n'a
pas mis assez d'argent sur le réseau
ferroviaire classique voilà certains le
savaient beaucoup ont tourné la tête
abandonnée on est rattrapé par la
réalité et ça c'est leur première
réponse et première accroche par rapport
aux contrats de performance
je vais le dire avec des mots diplomate
contrat de performance on est ravis
qu'ils existent mais à l'évidence les
deux milliards 8 sur fonds propres sncf
d'ailleurs sncf réseau attention là
aussi il ya parfois des idées un peu
confuse 2 milliards 8 oui sur fonds
propres des cncf réseau c'est pas
l'argent qui sort du budget de l'état
deux mineurs avides sncf réseau c'est
pas assez c'est pas suffisant pour aller
au au bout d'une ambition forte d'une
régénération consistante substantielle
de la de la matière du réseau et
l'indicateur grand public c'est le
scellage moyens voilà on est on est deux
fois plus vieux camp suisse et qu'en
allemagne et et au rythme du contrat de
performance on ne redresse pas la courbe
on en fait on ralentit l'érosion on ne
redresse pas l'âge l'âge moyen donc il
faut mettre plus d'argent pour non
seulement à limiter l'érosion mais
revenir à une trajectoire positive ou
petit à petit petit à petit à petit on
arrivera parce qu'il faut les années
pour faire ça dans la durée on arrivera
à avoir un état du réseau satisfaisant
[Musique]